thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Lobby
gamespot's weekly hangout every Tuesday
at 2pi Pacific right here on
gamingspot.com put it in your browser
put it in your Netscape that's where
you'll turn up right Peter Brown yeah
how you doing sad don't don't start you
son of a [__] Scott Butterworth how are
you doing In fairness he's always sad
he's such a little sadness yes Peter
sadness Brown air of on WE constantly is
that sadness is that it's one of those
words that sure just yeah on we yeah
yeah that was nice I've said that
because we were packs and you use that
very well in a video that I edited about
Night in the Woods I think oh yeah I was
joking about like Teen Angst and like
generic on we would say yeah Knight in
the woods is kind of that games like
you're playing a College Dropout it's
all about like life is sad and then like
oh it's my kind of thing so that sounds
like a word I would use indeed but hello
hello yes for those who don't follow
anyone on Twitter and they're wondering
why Peter sad although maybe I'm jumping
to maybe you're sad because you've been
qaing my F1 review for a week and it's
just so many spelling hours reviews
almost online for all uf1 fans it's
better than you give yourself credit for
okay no I'm sad for a very different
reason uh my final review I guess then
for gamespot.com among other finals as I
call it your final lap around the game
spot that was so good that we should
like change the lead but then the review
will become oddly self-referential so we
can't really do that listen you got to
throw it out on the lobby here so he
says credit still works for some
delightful wordplay partial credit uh
yeah sorry if you're watching the lobby
or listening to this in your iTunes ear
holes uh this is my final episode
hosting the lobby on my final week at
videogames.com yeah after five wonderful
years uh yeah yeah so let's see if we
can get through all this without me
turning into a bubbling wreck this isn't
about you this is about video games it
is he's out about our future not yours
gonna be just fine oh I don't know let's
let's see in a week or two uh yes we're
here to talk about video games uh
classic video games new video games and
and no that's that's it classic video
games in your video games we're gonna
talk about Duke Nukem 3D there's a game
I didn't think we'd be talking about
last week it's uh it's coming out again
there's another uh there's another
another version yeah you keep putting it
at the past year yeah but it keeps
coming back to the past year it's it's
listen if it get Returns on it You're
Gonna Keep they're just gonna keep
putting it out lawsuits cost money uh so
we played it so we're gonna talk a bunch
about what we played uh yeah it was
pretty good yeah yeah I always want to
talk about Battlefield one with Mr
Handlery which uh it's great actually we
were talking about how the beta was out
or the alpha was at we got access and
we're like I think this might be a good
Battlefield game uh and then seeing the
public reaction to it has been like yeah
yeah I think people are into this so
we're going to talk a little bit about
that uh but first of all
gentlemen Gears of four the fourth Gears
of War game it is a shame they didn't
officially call it yours before it was a
fan of puns that would have really sold
me on this particular iteration of Gears
we don't talk about judgment this is the
fourth Gears of War game uh at Pax
myself and Scott got to play horde mode
3.0 yeah uh the latest uh iteration on
horde mode of course it's so weird
talking about hard mode now because it's
it's now like the title of a like a sub
genre or something right like a type
whereas at the start it was just like
gears was the first one to do it yeah
yeah yeah yeah or like to form a lot it
was pretty much an afterthought I mean
or at least it wasn't Forefront of the
marketing it wasn't like we've got this
Innovative new multiplayer mode come
check out it was like oh and there's
this thing yeah it was like it's caught
on it was just like a playlist in the
multiplayer settings it was like do you
want death match or do you want I think
it was right and then it was a horror
mode of just like it's been a while
since I fired up gears too but I
remember it like arriving with very
little Fanfare and growing from there
right uh and we got to play hormone 3.0
which is with Rod Ferguson we did long
time director of gears just really cool
with that obviously that man knows the
games for sure and that has certainly
helped us actually get to the the first
boss wave at level 10. sounds like
Collision to me yeah a little bit yeah
we couldn't [__] talk Rod games he was
right there God this sucks he was
literally keeping us alive fortunately
he's not in this room so we can like
talk [__] now no exactly uh both John
Luke and Alexa fell a couple of times
we'll get into that in a second uh so
yeah Gears of War for horn mode 3.0 uh I
think the first thing to sort of talk
about with this is that like when the
the gears like death match beta came out
I was kind of like uh it's like it's
very similar to the old one which is
kind of good but also like there's
nothing new that's really bringing me to
this this series needs something new yet
for sure and I was actually quite
surprised about how different horde mode
is this time around yeah and I agree
with you I'm certainly more excited
about horde mode than the traditional
multiplayer because I remember playing
even before the beta I went to a preview
event and got Hands-On time with this
traditional competitive multiplayer
modes right and was kind of like okay
yeah this like feels a bit like older
gears and it's kind of fun but yeah
there's nothing really exciting about it
at all but horde mode was a lot more fun
I kind of instantly connected with the
new ideas they've layered on top I mean
it felt like The Horde modes I remember
and all the emergent craziness of
everything happening around you but
there's a lot more strategy on top which
I really appreciate it so this I
connected with way more than what I've
played of the competitive multiple I
guess the biggest change so far is that
they've straight up got like classes
which are yeah sort of they have there
was always like specific in a weird way
like the old horde modes were you know
it was such a Level Playing Field
because you were all doing the same
thing and then the only thing that like
differentiated people with skill in this
one you've straight up got like roles to
play there's a soldier a sniper a scout
a heavy and an engineer yeah speak to
one of those what about the scouter the
engineers well it's important to note
that like you are hard selecting a class
at the beginning it's not like oh you
can like customize your load like no no
you are picking a class and what that
means is uh it's different for every
class but a really good example is like
the Scout class so uh part of horde mode
is building fortifications and buying
weapons and upgrades and things like
that so you need currency to do that the
Scout gets double the amount of currency
of any other character type when he
picks up a power icon which is like the
currency of the game it's like energy
they kept referring to it or something
so you get way more mileage out of each
power icon if the Scout is the person
picking it up but the Scout is the
squishy one he's the squishy one so
that's why it's like the heaviest job in
the sniper's job to keep him alive but
it's a good example of how a roll
impacts the game because yeah anybody
can pick up a power icon but clearly it
works out best for everyone if the Scout
is the person doing it because you get
double the points or double the currency
yeah for doing that so yeah then they've
got the sniper class which is pretty
obvious uh you've got the heavy which
can like spawn with something like a
boom shot which would otherwise just be
a pickup yeah the engineer then is I
guess predominantly building yeah they
get a discount on like everything so
kind of like how the Scout gets double
currency they engineer anything they
build is cheaper right so you kind of
want that person hanging back by the
fabricator which is a kind of a new it's
basically what you build your base
around at the start of every match a
fabricator spawns you could move it
wherever and as soon as you put it down
that's a way to start but that is your
One-Stop shop for uh like upgrades and
actually you can revive allies that have
died that you didn't successfully revive
during a round and it's also where you
purchase all of your fortifications
um so yeah the engineer needs to kind of
hang out by the fabricator and be buying
stuff so that it you preserve your
currency Supply and what type of stuff
are you buying can you remember some of
those bits yeah well I mean like you can
buy like at the very basic level you can
buy like barbed wire and fortify your
immediate area but that's like the
really basic um you can build turrets
which cost a little bit more
um by the end you can be building like
oh God I'm trying to remember what the
really high level stuff was
unfortunately we only got to play the
first 10 waves yeah so as with 50.
exactly so traditionally there are 50
waves that it's true again here every
10th wave is a Boss Wave we only played
the first ten so we didn't see a lot of
the really high level stuff that you can
build but yeah suffice to say that as
you play you get more and more powerful
options they just cost more yeah um so
yeah you can really fortify your
position and actually one really good
piece of advice that that Rod gave me
that I was able to write about a little
later is the first 40 waves you're not
just trying to survive you're trying to
prepare for the final ten totally
because they are Far and Away the
hardest like by the time you get to the
final 10 waves all enemies have like two
and a half times hell two and a half
times damage two and a half times
accuracy and there's like bigger Boss
characters mixed in with the other
characters so the final 10 waves are
just like built to destroy yeah so
there's this weird mechanic where you
can basically like stick weapons in a
locker so yeah that's new as well or
something that comes in if they drop
their weapons you can just like get them
and actually you know what I'm not gonna
use this now I'm gonna stick it here
yeah so yeah you're oddly like you know
the little fortification Asian thing
that you create you're sort of like
arming us and arming it and so that you
can use it I guess for the like for the
the most the best strategy for the last
like 10 ways and what's really cool oh
sorry I didn't interrupt but just one
last quick thing about the Gun Locker
it'll actually reload any weapon that's
in it so oh yeah like a rocket launcher
yeah so it takes a little while but if
you have a rocket launcher and eight
rockets and you fire off seven uh in
older gears games it's like well you've
got one left and good luck but now if
you before firing that last shell off
you put it in a Gun Locker over time
you'll get more rockets and get more
mileage out of that gun so again
behooves you to play strategically and
think about what you're doing yeah sorry
go ahead Peter no I was just saying this
all sounds like really good I mean horde
mode for me was always one of those
things where like I got why people liked
it but for me like maybe a couple hours
in I would feel like just not interested
like yeah okay I got it I just need to
kind of get better but this sounds like
you have a whole range of options to
really just uh like strategize and
change how you play the game which again
this series really needs that so that's
very good to hear yeah and even then the
classes themselves once you've actually
picked one on the menu it kind of a
little bit deep maybe for our first run
through but they had these skill cards
that you basically assigned to your
character which gives you like boosts on
specific weapons or you know gives you
like more energy if you start like I was
the heavy and if I did like a one-on-one
takedown uh instead of like shooting
them from afar then I'd got like three
times as much uh energy drop there's
some really cool ones yeah well the nice
thing about those the gear cards is you
assign those before around so you're not
really messing with them like yeah once
you're in the match you're just focusing
on not dying
um but it's cool that a lot of those
give you kind of new ways to play and
actually one of the things I really like
about the Gear cars is they're very risk
reward there are some really basic ones
that are General that can be applied to
any class but they're kind of less
powerful but they're applicable to
anybody and they're easier to to use
yeah but then you'll get ones like the
sniper had an explosive headshot ability
right so if you're confident that you
can consistently land headshots that is
a really amazing car because you do way
more damage but it's also like uh how
confident are you that you can
consistently land a headshot when there
are people like rushing at you so again
kind of a risk reward you get less out
of of it if you're not able to actually
like land headshots but when you do it's
like a huge bonus yeah so you can decide
ahead of time there's a little bit of
strategy even among the the various
classes I was pleasantly surprised I
feel like it's probably like in a weird
way this requires a bit more teamwork
than the old horde mode kind of did as
well like you really need to make sure
you're not like stepping on each other's
Toes that was one thing I I felt like
especially because the map wasn't that
big the one we played you could see the
gameplay of it now it's we were kind of
all on top of each other for a lot of it
and like you know a lot of communication
with like some coming down the stairs
some coming from the the Red Barn
totally um a lot of yelling and I can't
imagine that like by the end there's
probably a lot more you know in the last
10 Rounds oh God again this was the
first 10 Rounds by the end I'm sure
we'll be screwing our heads off at each
other so yeah cautiously optimistic
about Horton what do you think Peter
just from like listening to us talking
about it I guess it's like what you know
like I said a second ago like this
sounds like a great sort of injection
like shot in the arm for this series
um because I kind of like am like I like
the environment in like the setting and
some of the the story for the gear
series but I always would maybe play the
campaign and then put it aside this
actually sounds like I may like this
better than the main game
my only basis for that is that this
sounds really interesting
um so yeah I'm curious to see how this
maybe impacts the balance of where their
you know the Coalition is paying uh a
lot of their efforts uh during
development yeah for sure I've seen a
lot of excitement just in the comments
on the Articles we've been putting up
people saying like yeah I play Gears for
horde mode
um and one thing I also mentioned in in
our Impressions video I appreciate that
this is very a very like true horde mode
it is like a small area and they're
waves of enemies because the the next
like
the other really big kind of horde
mode-ish thing I can really think of is
uh Call of Duty Zombies mode which has
evolved so much that it's not really a
horde mode anymore like you're actually
running through a level uh it's not
really a point defense or like tactical
thing anymore so I appreciate that this
is very like back to Roots but with some
new stuff layered on top it seems like a
really smart approach with how they're
doing it for sure uh you can learn more
about Gears of War 3 sorry four
what it's a horde three point five
television folks in Gears of War 4 it's
a little confusing Gears of four horde
3.0 hold on your butts coming to you
sometime soon didn't check the release
date oh well October 11 fire
uh October 12th thank you Scott
Butterworth uh you can check out more
about uh with Scott said was it October
12th 11th 11th October 11th coming to
you this October the 11th Halloween just
in time for Halloween and Valentine's
Day all right
I'm this is why this is why I gotta go
because my it's this it's it's the
Alzheimer's
that's the real reason that's a sad joke
this is like there's multiple layers of
sad in that gym that's true let's move
on
the more sad jokes that's speaking of
sad jokes
we got to play Duke Nukem 3D a Pax it's
a hell of a Segway actually can we do a
do-over I feel bad that someone's gonna
watch it out of gearbox especially
because it's actually all right yeah
okay all right we go good all right okay
oh no we should stop we should start
this with one of uh John St John's thing
because that would be cool right to the
King baby yeah you shake it baby should
I start with that one sure stop playing
2016. yeah well for the wrong reasons
maybe okay let's do it see what happens
shake it Scott Butterworth Duke Nukem 3D
is back it's got a new name it's called
Duke Nukem 3D 20th anniversary World
Tour yep nicely done
yeah Hail to the 10 points to Gryffindor
baby that's definitely a Duke reference
yeah and we got to play it a bunch we
went into a hotel room uh not in a
creepy way got Ash with all of our Limbs
and organs and clothing yep
but uh I got to play for like 30 minutes
you got to play for 45 minutes or so
yeah we were just kind of sitting there
chatting with the developers about what
they've kind of done with the game and
got to even play one of the the new
levels there are eight new levels which
we can't talk about yet which I was yeah
I wasn't gonna segue into that but yeah
there there are eight new levels from a
couple of the original designers which
is really cool they actually got some of
the Bands back together Johnson John
re-recorded all of his lines lines the
the voice of Duke um the original
composer Lee Jackson came back and it's
been music a couple of the key designers
are back to do new level stuff
um from what I understand all of the new
levels are kind of just remixing old
assets they've added very little because
they wanted it to feel like oh this
could have come out in you know 1996-97.
on one of the things that they've added
which you just saw in that gameplay a
second ago was the ability to well
they've redone it an entirely new engine
so uh I know I mean it kind of doesn't
look like it because they've tried to
stay as true to the original Duke as
possible but this is a you know it's got
3D buildings in it in 3D environments
and the original was using all manner of
weird magically to make it look like
there was 3D and when you look up at the
buildings and it does this like crazy
perspective thing it looks like you've
got like vertigo yeah when you switch
into the new version it doesn't do that
but they seem to have struck a pretty
good balance between like true to four
like the way your sort of nostalgia
remembers it as opposed to how it
actually looked but if you want you can
just swap back straight away by hitting
down on the d-pad I think to yeah and
it's on the fly like it'll switch back
and forth seamlessly which is kind of
cool I think I do it here actually in a
second they've got yeah that's what it
used to look like and is great for the
podcast listeners yeah look at that hot
Billiards action yeah and it's basically
Duke like it's straight off yeah it has
the the same it's it's one for one one
of the weird things in this level we
went into a bar and there was I did not
notice this when I was a kid but there
is a television with a white Bronco yeah
it's a [__] OJ reference yeah I
noticed that when I was watching them
weird yeah yeah and they were like oh
yeah that's totally dojo and they
weren't they weren't like subtle about
it all like yep that's what that was
yeah so they kept all that stuff in um
so one of the additions to this though
is developer commentary oh there we are
which is pretty cool the way they've
done it actually like they've just
dotted icons around the environments and
you just walk up to these little speaker
icons and hit play and you'll just have
somebody talking in your ear about that
specific part of the world it's kind of
interesting the way they've done it um
and so it's cool to get those insights
yeah fans of uh portal and Half-Life
will remember those because that was the
same way that valve put them into those
games
but I will say that from what we listen
to they sound like a lot more off the
cuff which I kind of like yeah it's
basically just like Randy Pitchford and
a bunch of like the developers just like
riffing it it was Ellen Blum and uh oh
who's the other uh Lord whose last name
I can't remember right now level Lauren
yeah he's changed itself
that's Mr level Lord to you
um it's great the stuff we were
listening to was very unvarnished like
oh yeah it was just super off the cuff
like if there's one point where Randy
pitch was like oh watch this as if we're
actually watching him play and it's like
that's not really how this works so it's
but it's kind of great that it's just so
off the cuff it was it was pretty fun to
just listen to a weird Rift track uh so
it's got the replay mechanic which I
think was in the it was the 360 version
console version of which Megaton right
Edition no so Megaton was the sort of
like supposedly Definitive Edition that
was available on good old games uh up
until about a year ago and then there
was some lawsuit yes
um so yeah so the rewind mechanic was
introduced in the 360 version they've
now kind of improved it so for people
who aren't familiar
um Duke 3D way back in the day if you
died you started over because it was
that kind of game so at one point you
started over in the level the level yeah
correct um so during one of the many
many reissues of this game uh a rewind
mechanic was added so if you died you
could actually back up your play session
by a few seconds and go like you could
not die and not have to restart so
they've actually uh not only included
that but improved it
um but I think they have left out some
of the content that was available in
Megaton I I should like double check
this one is basically just the four
original chapters and then this new one
which is embargo at the moment but we'll
be able to talk about yeah so be clear
it's like it's Duke 3D the first four
chapters and eight new levels that's
what's in this Edition and the replay
mechanic you can go back to the start of
the level as well yeah you can back yeah
it's actually um pretty uh lenient in
what you'll let it allows you to do uh
and that's pretty much it like it's it's
there's not really much else to say
about this if you you're a fan of Duke
Nukem 3D I think this is an interesting
thing to go back to I think they're
pricing at 20 bucks uh I believe it's 20
bucks and it's out in October it's out
early October so you don't have to wait
long to try it out for yourself and know
that later this month we'll have uh some
more information about the new levels
which we can't share yet but it'll be
available on gamespot.com is it weird I
feel like now is the right time for dude
what's the 20th anniversary 20 years not
like that you know what I mean like but
why because it is weird right because
it's it's also a game where you're like
you're in like a movie theater where it
is like weird it's like a porn theater
club with a girl masturbating on stage
like I was watching the video her hand
is going up and down like they're
they're not hiding anything you walk up
to a random woman give her money and say
shake it baby she's not even on stage
she's just hanging out yeah yeah that's
the weird one just like the girl
standing in the corner of a bar so he's
not just it's yeah like she takes the
money so I played I played this game
when I was probably like 10 years no
right yeah yeah probably right it was my
dad who showed it to me and looking back
now I was like oh wait he was weird like
I think I saw Terminator 2 when I was
like seven like yeah let me just have
all the media I wanted
um I remember watching RoboCop with my
dad when I was like way too young are
you watching RoboCop yeah yeah I don't
know how my mom let this one slip by
um well I mean video games are for
children right it might have been one of
those but like like Duke Nukem is one of
those series that like sure there have
been some efforts to like make it
relevant again but none of them really
struck a nerve and I feel like just you
know what let's just let's redo the one
like you were saying like and make it
look the way that we probably remember
it yeah which is an interesting
fictional memory of it yeah no I was
actually uh Ron Gilbert the designer of
maniac Mansion uh I was I was talking
about his new game thimbleweed Park a
few months ago GDC and it was this whole
idea of well we want this game to feel
like how you remember this game's
feeling because you don't remember them
as accurately as you think you do so
this is kind of the same thing where
it's like uh if you were to go back and
play the UN like unpolished original
version you'd be like oh my God this is
practically unplayable so this is now a
kind of definitive version that should
look and feel how you remember it and if
you don't then you can just sit down and
remember and go uh and then go back to
the geneja played on a big honking CRT
it just hums yeah constantly I know you
still have at least a couple by Peter
yeah
fair play uh that's it Duke Nukem 3D
20th anniversary World Tour it's a lot
of words uh do you know the release day
for that one's gone uh I don't remember
the exact day I know that it's early
October probably around the same time as
gears cool uh I'll have to double check
on the day in October
for that
dm3d2 awt wait okay right dn3d2awt yeah
we'll go with that I mean that sounded
accurate I have no idea 3D what was this
two two AWD no WT to a we're getting
we're gonna get to the bottom of this
fan it's important work leave it to us
I'm gonna change the three to a t as
well so it's
[__] sounds like a you are dense [__]
that's a bit appropriate sounding best
watch you might want to Dent [__] nope
oh yeah that word means something here
it does
all right uh okay last show Danny hello
way to go out thanks for coming on Scott
oh totally I'm I'm getting cycled out
yeah we got cycle in Mr Robert
handlerion bye guys
[Music]
it's not his name the handlerian sure
yeah what up Rob it's the last show and
you can't say my name right
Bob Handler boss Bobby Bobby only my dad
calls me Bob I never call you Bob uh I
used to be called Big Bob when I was
growing up like in Kentucky when I was
when I was a circus when I was a fat
baby
uh I didn't necessarily crawl with all
four I just kind of uh dragged myself
around the seal
yes a concealed so I got the nickname
Big Bob and I also didn't really speak
much oh my God too busy eating I was
such a fat white baby and they used to
like uh they used to like wash me in a
tub in front of the fire I grew I grew
up in like 1800s I swear to God when I
was and it would be like late night and
NFL was on so they used to call me the
refrigerator because I was a big just
fat white thing and then there was that
quarterback called The Refrigerator yeah
it couldn't have been a quarterback it
must have been a linebacker yeah yeah so
they call me the refrigerator also I'm
full of food please put ice near you
anyway video games
Rob Handler hey Battlefield one yeah the
first Battlefield uh the public beta has
been going on I feel like we've been
talking about this game for the past
couple of months uh quite optimistically
and there was sort of a week or at least
you know the best part of a week uh past
the public getting their hands on it for
the first time what do you what do you
make of the reception people seem to be
into it right yeah I think a lot of
people are really into it
um I hear like
I know like over the weekend they they
kind of fine Nest the conquest mode
right uh people were complaining that it
the matches were either too short or too
much of a landslide so they lengthened
like from 200 tickets to 300 tickets and
I think what it was was like during the
time limit was running out too quickly
or something like I had that having a
bunch actually yeah where it would it so
many games I played it would actually
get uh there'd be that comeback with the
um Behemoth rolling in or something like
that and and a couple times I actually
made a lot of you know um you know of a
comeback and then the time runs out and
I felt like you could you could just use
some more tickets basically to like have
that late game and and um yeah I think
they kind of tweaked that in a nice way
over the weekend so yeah it's weird the
first Alpha the the other one that we
played I had so many games that went
down to like 99 199 to 200. like super
super close matches and then this one I
felt like not so much I also felt like I
was getting the Behemoth train a lot
less than I was getting the blimp in the
first one yeah um but yeah I guess
they're still tweaking it uh but I guess
we talked last week about sort of the
map and how it was different and whatnot
um we've played a lot of this now at
this stage like probably between the two
of them you're talking like the 30 hours
maybe or something like that yeah uh
what do you make of Battlefield are you
are you more optimistic now after
playing a bunch of this one yeah I think
they're you know compared because we
also got to play close Alpha other
people did not but they kind of
introduced a lot of elements that I was
really looking forward to namely vehicle
Loadout classes
um the fighter plane for instance in the
closed Alpha was very much just a strict
air game uh they hinted at always in the
closed Alpha they hinted at the ability
to change your Loadout and I was just
excited to see them put that in the open
Beta in that I could now take a plane
that's already inherently great for
air-to-air combat but now I can like add
a secondary trench gun and be a little
bit of a uh and have an evolved role on
um on ground uh enemies I think there
are now these things that open up with
vehicles and being able to change them
according to like your play style you
can add more people in a tank or flip it
and have just your two side turrets Bop
right okay and I didn't get to use it
but there's supposedly there's like a
flamethrower tank that you can customize
with a heavy tank like they have added a
lot of cool things and the other thing
they added were the I don't know if you
mess around with it where the um the
three kind of power what they call them
Elite packages no I haven't seen these
the flamethrower oh yes the minigun and
like an anti-tank rifle that are
scattered around the map uh I just got
it with the I got some time with the
flamethrower um so you have like a
little bit of a health boost I think
you're wearing like armor what's the
distance on it like the flavor is pretty
good it's a little more short range I
know the minigun is like definitely
farther and then you know the farthest
being like the anti-tank it's like a
huge anti-tank sniper rifle right so it
does great on like any kind of vehicle
um so the other thing I guess is we were
really really early on the horses last
week yeah what's I felt like this is one
of these things where people are gonna
have to get some time on model before
that we can really see if it's good or
not what's your verdict on the horses
now I think the Turning is very tough I
feel like I'm fighting this horse
consistently maybe I didn't feed enough
carrots I don't know maybe you were
feeding a carrots yeah well I think you
just you can get really a
I think if you are trying to turn
quickly the horse doesn't like it I
think you just got to be gentle with
your turn turning and because right it
can buckle up right if you mess around
with it too much when you're trying to
turn around he'll freak out and next
thing you know you're now stalling and a
horse is freaking out and a guy's just
sniping your face like okay but that
horse has no problem just storming into
battle with bullets like the Slime yeah
explosions right pull it the wrong way
hold up there were a bunch of gifts over
the weekend of I think too that you see
uh of course this was gonna happen one
was a guy riding a horse with the
flamethrower guy I'm talking about and
the minigun guy on the horse so it's
just this three-person freaking death
machine oh my God uh another one was
yeah the movement's tough but this one
guy you know of course someone's gonna
have it down he was like writing up the
stairs and getting on roofs and jumping
off roofs no they were calling like
Assassin's Creed Horrors and then like
flying into like the window of a second
story building uh
so yeah someone will Master it I yeah I
had tough time with it I think it's
definitely some uh practices involved
right A lot of people talking about how
the tanks are there's this whole thing
where like our tanks op and whatnot do
you think it's one of these cases where
we have the public beta and like it
takes a couple of hours before people
feel comfortable about like where they
should be and you know where they're not
exposed and stuff like that or do you
think the tanks need a little bit of
tweaking uh
I go back and forth I think
I think you just have to realize that
you know your infantry you are the
lowest form on the battlefield I mean
lower than the horse yeah well I would
say so a horse has some I feel like some
sort of like protection right I think
people can shoot the horse opposed to
you uh but I think when you see a tank
coming at you yeah you don't charge it
like I said throw grenades
chill out figure out a way to take it
down there are artillery pieces on the
field I've had luck getting on those and
battling it out but at the end of the
day like I I will say that I I think the
one class that I always stick to is the
assault class just because you can you
can take on a tank in the assault class
you have multiple gadgets and abilities
to to do some major damage but
everything else it's like maybe a
grenade a couple grenades but if you get
you look around just know your
surroundings right if you've got eight
guys next to you and there's one tank
coming in you can take that tank on like
I that's I've been in that tank where
it's eight guys everywhere I can't shoot
you know everyone in time uh in that
like everyone's throwing grenades at me
like you just you you're done yeah but
yeah I think it all depends they could
be turned on a little bit because I've
just had runs like over the weekend I
had some buddies the land ship has two
side turrets that are the um basically
the Cannons and oh my God yeah I was
telling you like we went like 30-0 oh
really just like sweeping up sweeping
because you know you can repair the
tanks that's the thing is you can always
survive in some manner like throw some
smoke and bounce out and repair
um same goes with the plane uh the I'm
just rambling here but the attack plane
has this huge
57 millimeter cannon on the front of it
and it's a tank Hunter is what's called
an oh my God you just can wreck
everything one shot kills on like
bombers and everything uh a question
about actually Affinity asking I'm
having or saying I'm having the toughest
time getting used to ancient planes uh
you've always been a fan of the air
combat does it take a couple of hours to
get used to them is there any like one
plane that you should try and like get a
hold of to ease your way in yeah of the
three the attack plane is definitely one
I would stick to because you can have a
back turret uh and guys are pretty
generous people will get into your plane
I feel like for the most part in kind of
uh you know depending on how good you
are they'll they'll stick it out with
you but um yeah I think it's tough I
think
um
in general yeah you just have to know
when to like bounce out and repair
because I think I was telling you like
you get your Rudder shot up you're now
immobilized yeah you can't make those
turns which is really great I think for
that game to change significantly
um but yeah I don't know it all depends
I think
I think it's tough like I have I use
joysticks I haven't been able to use
that yet but I think um the the flight
controls are okay it's just tough the
button layout is actually not working I
don't know if you notice reload which is
very vital and eject the same button so
my goodness right a good hour into the
game I had to consciously lightly tap
the button to reload and not cool down
which will eject
um so yeah and you can't customize these
controls on Console unfortunately right
so when you eject are you then just an
effective ground troop at that point or
are you hindered at all because you were
flying and maybe you don't have enough
gear yeah right I think this is one of
the coolest things they've done uh is
tank or sorry vehicle namely tanks and
planes when you eject having spawned
into it you are now assuming that tank
class which you then can customize as
well but you have a a lower
um uh form I think it's just like a it's
like yeah almost uh it's like a just
like a pistol rifle um so yeah you do
not have your your one of four uh
typical loadouts so you're at a
disadvantage which I think is is good
because it kind of pulls yeah right
exactly yeah and and it kind of keeps
people from I think abusing that because
this was kind of a battlefield thing
right yes getting to the you know
flanking them and then just ejecting
them totally you know you gotta chill
out on that yeah there's a great video
of all the sort of tips about planes you
can check out on gamespot.com as well
last question on this uh which I'm kind
of interested in as well Pinchy screen
asking any Landing or still magic auto
repair
have they can you because I've I saw one
accidentally Land one and repair but
they couldn't take off again what yeah I
think I like crashed buggy or something
you can't land the things right you like
here's the thing is you can land it but
it's not meant to land so it feels like
it feels like there's a nice bubble
um beneath my wheels on the ground where
you're just bouncing around
like guaranteed the way the wheels
aren't even like you know uh yeah or
they don't respond which is a bummer
because I love taking off from runways
in Battlefield right yeah so that leads
me to believe that like you're always
going to be spawning into them
mid-flight which is a bummer I don't
know there you go Battlefield one
exciting times uh let us know what you
think of the public beta in the comments
below
all right that's it wrap it up and get
out of here I don't think so man
[Music]
International sign for let's get out of
here that as everyone knows this uh yeah
probably uh yes this is my final episode
of uh the lobby my final week here at
gamespot.com new episode of the point
coming up on Friday I think maybe it's
not the point it's that GTA video I was
working on yeah did New York when I was
at that WWE thing I want to see that fun
yeah yeah Hot Shots that's c100 is
really good for taking shots of shots of
freaking buildings and stuff slow mode
too yeah how you feeling I'm feeling all
right yeah it's weird it's super weird
because you're like you're leaving the
job that like [__] I mean we all worked
really hard to like work in this
industry and like the break-in in the
first place and he's like I do anything
for that job I do anything for that job
and then to like walk away from it is
like a weird thing it's like it's yeah
it feels like uh it feels like running
into danger like why would I do this but
that's that's characteristic of I think
maybe some of the risks you took to get
this job in the first place right and it
panned out think of it yeah think of it
in terms of graduating that's good I
like that that's a good smell that's
good yeah yeah I guess it's been five I
can't believe it's been five years how
long have you been living here we've
been living here I like you've been
working here uh almost five years it'll
be five years uh next month it's nuts it
feels like like now I was look I was
looking at my my Gamespot profiles like
I think it I think I started in 2005 I
was like a lurker for like two years
um and then I think I registered then so
I'm like almost working here as long as
I was registered I'm thinking about
working here yeah so that's yeah it's
pretty crazy it's a pretty nice trip
yeah it's gonna be weird uh Sean Luke
standing in the corner and I saw Mary
looking like she was crying at her desk
earlier and now I'm worried that there's
like some sort of secret Montage
situation no it's just of me and Rob
great
great that would that would definitely
um make me cry ah
is this is this the thing that's
happening
is it yeah all right let's do it roll
down afterwards
oh man
[Music]
the first game I ever completed was the
secret of Monkey Island on the Amiga 600
I was about seven and it took me three
months RTS RTS
A Link to the Past it's it's because his
name is LinkedIn
Jesus anyway I'm Irish handling hot
potatoes is kind of my thing ah Jesus
Christ hello welcome to random encounter
the live streaming show we play a
different random game on Tuesdays and
Thursdays September this level this had
like incredible water graphics oh yeah
remember from my War Graphics thing look
at that what's up what's the Deep what's
the bullets bubbles
Thunder Cube
563 take that the continent of Africa
how many of you are there nah no I'm
freaked out as well you're a tiny monkey
man here we go this is it this is it
this is it
no no
this is for Poland
and for Paris and for for people who had
that mustache before you came around and
made it unfashionable
so come by your PlayStation Portable
today sure it costs a month's wages but
if the games are bollocks you can always
watch porn on the bus
[Music]
Sean welcome to the point hello welcome
to the point hello and welcome to the
point and if you're watching this on
gamespot.com the brand new website hey
check it out look at it it looks all
shiny and clean and new and stuff and
yeah you guys are riding does kind of
look like giant ball should games
diverge away from film or is David cage
onto something with Beyond Two Souls are
we just steps away from being an
interactive storytelling medium it makes
it more understandable but it doesn't
mean we have to accept it online
communities have the ability to be so
much more and we all have a part to play
Hey there this week on the point I've
just realized I've got a bunch of last
gen games I haven't completed yet and
it's freaking me out
do the intro
hello and welcome to the lobby games box
weekly hangout every Tuesday at 2PM
Pacific right here on gamespot.com
should we ask John Travolta watch
Rambo's first name is
[Applause]
[Music]
neck tattoo it's weird that someone is
moving that I don't believe it
[Laughter]
welcome
full dweller welcome
to the Wasteland
hello and welcome to the point this week
brought to you by the power of the
Oculus Rift a fantastic new device owned
by Facebook
whoa depending on what games you play
it's either changed irrevocably or it
never changes at all so the one thing
you don't want to feel when you're
partying with sixty dollars of your
hard-earned cash is that you're getting
some truncated version of the full game
and guess what when you launch a game
with that much optional content that's
how people are gonna feel
if you watch the point frequently then
you know that one of the things that
fascinates me the most are the times
that video games impact on our real
world lives but it's just kind of
pathetic to talk about which is again
why I was you know happy that depression
Crest you know came up because then
people who are having issues can then
cope with other issues like you know it
Sparks up a lot of conversations and I
always find them cathartic so I think
that's a really good thing so today on
the point we're going to talk about how
development deadlines affect creativity
and we're going to demonstrate so by
creating today's episode in one day
[Music]
thank you
hi there good morning and welcome to
Warsaw here in Poland home of cede
project red the team Behind The Witcher
a gaming franchise based around the
short stories and novels of Mr Andrew
shipowski and now one of the most
anticipated games of 2015.
[Music]
so put on your best pair of shoes today
we explored the world of wild Hunt
[Music]
how do you create War zones in which
acrobatic pilots and hulking mechanical
robots both have their place today on
the next big game we break apart the
anatomy of a Titan format Yeah you sort
of have your fingerprints in essentially
like it's not all most of lizards uh
games since since the early 90s for good
or ill
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
damn dude ah
[__] you Mary kids yeah right
oh thank you so much Jesus I don't know
how she put that together we had a long
weekend and everything thank you so much
married I was oh
Geez Louise
you're left in the place in a different
shape than it was when you got here I
mean okay you've done a lot for the site
man and you've definitely inspired a lot
of us hey we all did that's why we did
it right that's why we [__] did it
because we wanted to like
add to the sign make it like cool like
it was when when we were like looking
from the outside in you know yeah and I
think you did probably more in that
effort than a lot of us are able to
thank you so much
I mean that's the only thing that makes
like leaving feel okay because it's like
I would not be leaving this if it wasn't
like the life and I mean
you know when you have a dream and then
like you reach that dream and then you
need to like figure out what the new
dream is and like this side is giving me
everything like I'm like I met my wife
because I moved here like it's giving me
everything so
I wouldn't be moving if I wouldn't be
leaving if it wasn't for for something
else that I felt like I like needed to
do uh yeah so I love news on all that
new stuff whenever I'm not going
anywhere else I'm not going to any other
website or anything I'm a massive
Gamespot fan and I will leave here and
get I get to be a Gamespot fan again and
you know set it as my homepage again you
harass me in the comments yeah
exactly I mean that's like that's
that's what happens to everyone who
lives here like that's we've got you
know Josh Shaw and Dan Mark in the chat
like Chris is in the chat like we're all
fans of this place and like even after
we leave like that that shows you out
how much this place means to people that
that you know they stay connected even
though even though we're gone uh like
even when we had Kevin in here a couple
of months ago you know it's just like
this place in it like Brands itself on
you uh not just because of what the name
of the site
and what the site means to people but
just because the people the people who
are here you know and that's where I'm
gonna miss the most Bye by mile
ugh it's not goodbye it's not it's not
around it's Sea Ranch I'm gonna be in
here recording a podcast where Formula
One every Tuesday probably but you can't
look at us that'll make things so
awkward
wear stash
and who knows like you know who knows
maybe we'll we'll you know we'll maybe
I'll do a hot collabo every now and
again or something and you know in the
long in the future future but uh yeah uh
all right I guess if this is my the last
live show I want to thank everyone I
want to thank God I want to thank Rich
Gallup and Jeff gerstman and Ryan
McDonald and Vinnie Caravella for making
me want to do this in the first place
um Chris Beaumont and Ben Howard
[__] for taking a risk on me uh
you know I applied for the job a bunch
of times and didn't get it and those
were the guys who uh who believed in me
and shepherded me through this so thanks
dude
um Andy Bauman I create a best creative
partner I ever had who if it wasn't for
him none of that stuff would have looked
as good as it did uh and then everyone
here you guys everyone in the back too
many people to mention you know here who
are here right now and who are who who
have gone over the years
um thank you so much and of course to
everyone for watching this stuff because
without you guys
I never would have gotten the game spot
I never would have gotten to America I
never would have been able to take the
next leap so thank you all so much uh
and
if it's the morning where you are I'm
sorry if you cried because it's [__]
just cry first go back to past go back
to bed if you're in the UK go to bed God
damn it all right that's a show thank
you so much for watching the lobby uh
let's subscribe on iTunes listen to it
on your ear hose rate subscribe if you
want to know what I'm doing next follow
me on Twitter I don't know Daniel Dwyer
it's hard to spell but there's not many
of me so you should be able to find it
and of course uh do the same thing as
what I'm gonna do and keep tuning into
the lobby every Tuesday at 2PM Pacific
and keep tuning in to gamespot.com the
best video game website in the
[__] world see you next time
foreign